it kind of comes back to me of like it's
not just the movie right making the
movie is the experience and the
process and the human beings who put
their fingerprint on every little
section of the movie
blame what AI tools have you started
using oh zero I've never touched one I I
honestly I keep getting ads on my social
media and I'm keep like Xing I wouldn't
even know what I would use them for
that's how ignorant I am of it and uh
you know I I try to uh maintain that
ignorance as much as I can I know that
um there are some writing tools and
things that are being used and I know
that it's
um scary
and I don't like it
um
I don't know what what tools do you use
out of curiosity oh well chat gbt I have
tried and then a few
um illustration programs which I'm just
skimming the surface I claim no
proficiency and do you challenge like do
you chat gbt do you put in an idea and
just see what comes out or what what
they what it creates and
sure sure yeah absolutely I have tried
from asking it questions on a price for
something and basing it on the fact that
they it's not since I think 2020 or 2021
since it's been updated yeah uh but you
can ask any type of question
uh and you get a very interesting answer
back and and there's always disclaimers
usually if it's a certain you know yeah
you know this is an AI and and no
generalities are made or different
things but you can put in an idea I did
try a few story ideas and said please
write this story here are going to be
some of the uh parameters to the story
here's the character I was surprised at
what was spit back and I mean it was
instantaneous yeah so that part is scary
I will say that the story that was spit
back missed the human element it didn't
have little quirks and idiosyncrasies
for the character was perfectly written
but it wasn't
um let's say didn't didn't have a
quote-unquote voice of an author right
okay so what I think about it is I think
that it will absolutely get to a place
where
it could be used to replace writers I I
think that's absolutely true I think
it's because
screenwriting right now especially is
structure based there is a paint by
numbers scenario that um
80 percent of films adhere to and if you
can have that structure and you can have
the hero's journey and the you know the
familiar themes that we've been using
basically since you know Socrates or
whatever
then there will will be a way for AI to
figure out enough human foibles in order
to make it work
that terrifies me uh I don't want that
and I feel like that's one of the
reasons why the writer skill is striking
right now
um I think that is a incredibly good
reason to to strike and I feel like
there's a lot of
legitimate rules that can be put into
place to you know ebb that growth
because I don't think we need it I think
it should be resigned or sorry a
reserved for things to play with on the
internet of like what if I ask at these
questions let's see what it comes back
with
um but that's just my opinion uh I feel
like tricking us into believing that uh
artificial intelligence is human is
really just about
finding the right balance of weirdness
and neuroses because people are weird
you know but it won't have the dramatic
important Human Experience that uh you
know I feel like drama demands but it
may be able to fool us into thinking
that that's what it is
you talk about people being weird so
that weirdness in a character that's in
a TV writer's room and you have writers
fleshing out why would this person do
this let's have it this happen is AI
really do you think uh at a stage where
it could
become that weird or is that only
something that comes from being human I
mean I'd like to say that it's just
something that comes from being human
I'd like to say that I I'd like to
believe that you know what I worry about
is
um
you know I mean look I think it was last
week that a bunch of the uh
um had
people scientists about AI you know
wrote this letter saying that it's in
you know a major threat uh to humanity
and if they feel that right if they're
so concerned with AI being a threat to
an existential threat to humanity
how much of a shorter trip is it to them
being able to write a good sitcom I
don't know I don't like it I don't like
the idea of it being able to put people
out of work I'd like to believe that no
computer could ever do the work that I
and my colleagues do
but that being said I think that's one
of the reasons that it's so dangerous is
um
how much of what we write affects people
how much of what we write makes changes
what people think or convinces them to
you know
do this or not do this or you know I I
always think about
when I was a kid I grew up in the South
you know and I knew not to be racist
because of different strokes
um I was probably six you know when I'm
watching the show and I there was a bad
kid and he was the racist kid and I'm
like okay that's a bad guy I'm not going
to be the bad guy despite you know
whatever hate I might have been
surrounded by you know extended family
or
school or whatever that taught me
something and I don't like the idea of
an AI generated thing deciding what
lessons Humanity should be learning does
that make sense it does
um yeah I don't I don't like that so I
hope I hope we can put a pin in it and
just like take the creating of drama out
of uh Hal's hands uh so we can just do
it ourselves you know
have you thought about venturing into it
to see the capabilities and maybe
realizing that some of the fear is
unfounded or or maybe you would see that
actually it's more terrifying than you
realize you know what it's I'm just not
that into it I'm not that interested in
it to be honest with you like I'm
concerned about it but like like I said
this thing of all the scientists signing
that letter that's concerning for me
like I don't want to play with it I
don't want it to know where you know I
don't know what Ai and GPS and cookies
and you know all these things combined I
I don't need artificial intelligence
knowing where I live and what my social
security number is but I don't know it's
mostly just that I don't understand it
and I fear it
um so I'll wait until you know uh
somebody more savvy than I am says hey
you know what this is great for
this and as long as it's not getting
away without having to do my homework
I'll probably get on board at that point
do you edit your own films no I don't I
but I'm always right there I I tend to
sit like annoyingly close to my editor
and uh then uh second guess at every
single step
um no I I very much enjoy the editing
process and working with great editors
who are uh intuitive and talented and
they I've been lucky that every editor
I've worked with has made me better at
uh what I do so
okay you said intuitive so what if there
was an AI program that was almost as
intuitive as a live body
who had years of experience and I
believe that that's I mean if that's not
here then it's soon to be here you know
uh that makes sense
um
again I just I mean
look you you want to break it down to
the very basics of who I am right you
know I'm a union guy I'm a worker I'm
you know uh we're striking right now for
the writer's Guild the last thing I'm
interested in doing is taking work away
from one of my crew members who I would
always say you know the editor is one of
the key key components of making a great
film so
it just I don't love it you know but I
also know that we're cutting Corners now
in you know uh technology that we
couldn't do before we were talking about
the digital cameras you know we we had a
zoom lens on this film which is the
first time that I not had a giant box of
prime lenses you know this one he would
just zoom the lens it was like all right
and so we got that for a lot less than
it would take to get the the Primo
lenses right okay so what's the
difference between me cutting that
corner and me cutting the corner with
um maybe I only bring on an editor at
the end of the process instead of the
beginning I don't know it just makes me
uneasy I I like having a person that I
can bounce off of and we can talk and
and at the end of the day it kind of
comes back to me of like it's not just
the movie right making the movie is the
experience and the
process and the human beings who put
their fingerprint on every little
section of the movie and so when this
film is finished it won't just be a
bland Weaver picture it'll be uh you
know Blaine and Dave and Jeremy and you
know Mike and all these guys who put
this movie together and made it it's
ours right because we each weighed in
and fought our fights and
compromise when it was time to
compromise but we we made this thing
together and
it just doesn't sound fun to me